hey everyone it's Michael BOS from
orderflows and welcome to the orderflows
market analysis for Tuesday June 20 2017
and it was another quiet day on the
economic news front and another day with
heavy selling in oil we got down below
43 bucks I think we closed around 4335
we're down about 75 cents in the crude
uh inflation looks very weak right now
uh oil
prices you know the declines in oil
prices are starting to get um more
attention by the fed and uh stocks which
which rallied yesterday on Monday nice
big rally you know they they gave back
some of it uh today on Tuesday and the
market fell back uh Dow was down about
0.3% that said um you know there was
there was a few trading opportunities
you know Monday there was a lot of nice
opportunities Tuesday there there was a
few um but I said you know it was kind
of a quiet day overall but um you know
we'll I'll I'll show you the ones that
you know really stood out the most with
the order flow um before we jump in the
brief disclaimer this president
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation a buy or
sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
training contains substantial risk and
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results tools I use in this presentation
are the order flows Trader which is the
volume footprint chart and I talk about
the delta
scalper in many markets you I show you
some great examples of how the Delta
scalper picks areas in the market where
based on the order flow the market is
changing from a supply driven Market to
a demand driven Market what that means
is a market that's been selling off
turns and starts to Rally or a demand
driven Market a market that's
rallying gives a sign that it's moving
from a demand driven Market to a supply
driven market so basically picking not
picking a top but alerting you to a
potential top in the market again you
know I I don't even though you know I
talk a lot about uh turning
points it's really the market telling me
that the market is turning it's not me
trying to predict oh there's a turning
point here no rather you know I'm just
reading what's happening in the market
and and the market is just natur is just
telling you that hey you know there's a
turning point here a potential shift in
supply and
demand so you know start in the five
years five years was was interesting cuz
you know going back to to you know this
morning 5:00 4:00 you you had your high
you had your ratio you got a
Divergence and again I always say you
know whenever you get a high with the
and you have a Divergence and you got a
a ratio in the order flow you know
that's a great opportunity to uh take
that trade and you know so here we at
our high we sold off from our high down
to your low you got a ratio no
Divergence is the ratio we rally back up
to a new High um with the Divergence but
you know what else do you see in here
you see Delta scoper giv us sell at this
High Delta scalper next bar off the low
giving a buy Delta scalper giving a sell
up here so you know you literally you're
selling off from your high down to your
low you got a Buy Signal you got a sell
signal on your high a Buy Signal just
off the low another sell signal just off
the high you do start rallying back up a
later 950 you had the Delta scoper again
give us a sell signal you have a ratio
no Divergence but the sign in the next
bar is this bullish ratio so again you
know if you're short off this you know
the next bar is telling you hey hey um
you might want to think seriously about
getting out of this position so again
you know that's what the order flow does
it tells you not only does it tell you
when um you know when to take trades but
could tell you when to get out of Trades
you know based on what's happening in
the market why should you let the market
go all the way up to your stock price
just to take you out if you could read
what's happening in the order flow um
you know get out now you know this one
bar here at 926 where we have this nine
Lots here you know I was very keen on
see what was going to happen when we
trade back into into this area you know
this thin spot so to speak and you know
I wanted to see this you know fill it
you know I treat these as gaps and we
did we came back in now I was really
looking for this bar to turn red and
trade lower instead you just got one
tick through you filled the Gap and you
continued
rallying you know I I I really you know
I felt that if we could stay below this
this area you know I think we could have
traded at least down to six 5 and A2 um
but anyway we didn't we filled the Gap
and you know as in normal Gap analysis
you close the gap and you continue up in
your
direction um you know nothing uh really
later in the order flow to get too
excited
about but you know really the the the
big things were early you know just you
know five with the ratio with the
Divergence you hit the low start ring up
you get another Delta scalper buy
another Delta scalper sell I mean it's
literally just bouncing off you know
highs and lows
okay so just staying on the interest
rates for a while this is the bonds and
again you got a few interesting things
here you know 5: in the morning 5:30 you
got a ratio with a Divergence you nice
eight tick sell off for you rally back
up and you got another ratio with
Divergence and unfortunately it doesn't
sell off it just comes back up here
stops you you had Delta scalper giving a
sell this one didn't work out and it
came right back up here um new highs and
another Delta scalper but it's a Delta
scalper on a green bar so I'm not
looking to get short on a green bar this
Delta scalper cell here on a green bar
you know you need the bar to to continue
down you know be red you don't want to
be getting short on a bar that can't
even
close um can't even close lower than it
open when you're looking to get short
the Market's rallying while you getting
short there but you know the thing that
I want to point out is you know going
back since
743 you know even though earlier you had
the Divergence here and you know 2 hours
later you came back up and took out the
Divergence but you know in more recent
in history you got 743 failed Divergence
759 failed Divergence um 950 you got a
Divergence and you know when I start
seeing three or four you know three
usually failed divergences I'm looking
for the fourth and what I'm going to be
looking for is when we start coming back
up to the high I'm going to be looking
for some aggressive buying to come in
and here you're coming up you hit the
high you got you know a buying in
Balance another buying in Balance just
next to it so you know I I know that
when I start seeing fail Divergence is
in you know sort of grouped together on
a chart that chances are if we're going
to test those highs we can still go
higher and so this is this was a nice
place to get it get long he said I'm not
big necessarily on on buying breakouts
however you know on trending markets if
you could buy a breakout you know you're
going to be rewarded nicely and you know
any sort of sign that the Market's
trending will help you and to me failed
divergences are a sign that the Market's
you know it's got some trending underway
and you come up you know see this is a
nice six ticks right here you know five
ticks six ticks you know I mean if you
could just take five ticks out of the
bonds every day on a one lot that's you
know that's some decent money you can do
that with you know a you know if if you
can just make 10 ticks in the bonds a
day at the end of you know every trading
day of the year you know that's $70,000
more or less at the end of a year I'm
not saying that everyone could do it but
again you know if you know think in that
terms I mean you don't have to you know
make $5,000 on every trade you know if
you can squeeze you know I say squeeze
rather if you can grind out your profits
consistently you that's what's going to
keep you in the game longer it's not the
big home runs yeah it's always nice to
hit a home run on a trade but you know
they being consistent is more
important so you rally up from um you
know this 0809 area all the way up to 15
you got another ratio with Divergence to
sell off another six ticks you start
rallying back up you hit the high again
and then you close for the
day okay so the next Market I'll talk
about our beans soybeans Zs and again
you know soybeans is not as glamorous as
trading crude or as uh glamorous as
trading um e- minis but you know beans
are are a great contract for trading out
of uh you know a lot of these
agricultural contracts are actually very
nice for trading and you know they do
follow orderflow quite nicely
so you know 8:30 is the reopen after the
evening session you know goes into a
halt stage and reopens at 8:30 you know
835 you've got this red arrow here you
got the Trap traders in you know coming
up right in here and we rally uh sorry
we sell off into new lows you got down
here you have you point of control on
this green bar right at the bottom you
got a bullish ratio you know there's
some supportive buying coming in here
right to me this bar is very bullish
what happens selling comes right back in
in the next bar in you can see the
imbalances so you know even if you're
getting long here you get stopped out
it's not the end of the world right bad
trades happen you do get stopped out on
trades you know fortunately you could
have caught this previous bar here a
nice move
down um you know covered it here look to
get long take the loss uh then we come
down into this low here you know we got
you know at this level here 928 there
was some decent volume 967 756 even 300
you you got about 2,000 contracts you
know supporting this market so um you
know we got through that and you know
Market's looking for its low hits its
low down here at 926 another sizable bid
at down here 210 Lots traded you got a
zero print you got point of control
right at the bottom so it's kind of
similar to this other bar here that
failed however the the big difference is
you got the positive Delta so you got a
Divergence and I say you know you got a
blue number it's a ratio it's
zero and what happens the market rallies
right you got a ratio with a Divergence
Market rallies I always say buy those
ratios with Divergence you know this one
is just a ratio no Divergence this one
is a ratio
Divergence and you know it goes up from
you know the 927 area all the way to 930
starts coming back down you know hits
back down to 6 and2 doesn't test that
low um and we just go sideways start
rally I'll say rallying but um you know
we get back all the way up to 931 Delta
scalper gave a sell then you get down
here right at 928 and a
half Point control at the bottom you got
a bullish
ratio next bar Delta scalper and over
the next two bars you shoot up about uh
you know almost 2 cents before you know
you sell them back down into this area
where you I know there's support coming
in down
here and then you just sort of go
sideways into the
close the other market I'll talk about
really quick is uh the euro currency
although there's something interesting
in the euro currency this morning
and let me just find the chart here I
could pull the chart in and talk about
it it's it's right here um time was it's
about 9:30 in the morning ish I
think and again you know it's it's about
understanding order flow you know um
understanding what you're seeing in the
market now okay you got Delta scoper
given a sell here but it's a green bar
okay and again you know shouldn't be
looking to take shorts on green bars
right um you know if the bar was red
that's you know when you should be
looking to take the short not on a green
bar but anyway why you know what's
happening here is actually it's not
Delta scer this is Delta surge I'm sorry
um but still I mean you know again you
shouldn't be looking to take the trade
on on a green candle you should be
taking it on a red it's a Delta surge so
it's telling me you know negative Delta
is building up but what's happening is
the Market's rallying green candle green
candle now you know people have written
to me you know quite nasty emails
actually and you know say oh this Delta
surge that you're giving out sucks you
know look I I put it on my chart and you
know they told me to sell here and I
sold it and the market rallied I got
stopped out I lost money well you don't
you're not understanding you know first
of all you're understanding order flow
and how to use the indicator you know
and secondly you know I mean like I say
you always say you know if you're
looking to get short Market's got to
confirm it right rather than just an
indicator saying hey get short here and
oh okay I'll get short here you know I I
hate to use the term you know your
friends are jumping off a bridge do you
jump off too no you sit there and you
analyze what's going on and sit here and
look at what's going on you got negative
Delta negative
Delta and why you know because you have
supportive buying coming in you got 117
116 129 112 here on this on this you
know people coming in and and bidding
the market people are selling it yeah
people are selling into this looking to
go lower but there's still just more
passive buying coming into the market
more people supporting this Market
that's why you have the negative Delta
just because you have negative Delta
doesn't necessarily mean the Market's
selling off you know when you have
negative Delta on a green bar it's
telling you there're supportive buying
coming and just like you have it over
here 252 341 170 you know you see the
market pop up a little bit then it's
coming back in almost around these same
levels you know at uh 91 90 you know the
these areas even in the next bar
stronger negative Delta minus 199 but
look you got supportive buying here 129
93 93 90 83 what do you got trading on
the offer side you got squat you know
one bar 10 one level 108 everything else
40 22 39 you know 71
12 but there's more selling going on
there's more selling into the bid than
buying from the offer that's why you
have the negative Delta you have
negative Delta because you know someone
sells into the bid that's minus one
someone buys from the offer that's plus
one so even though you have negative
Delta you have negative
Delta based on supportive buying coming
in and it's helping to move this market
up so you know watch that stuff when it
happens around lows okay because it's
it's important or you know the opposite
around
highs and what happens so again you know
Delta surge you know yeah it gave a
signal it's just reading the Delta
that's what the Delta surge does it
doesn't take all this other stuff into
account you know the way the Delta
scalper does but you know it's just
reading the Delta by itself but what
it's got negative Delta on green bars
should be alerting you to something you
know you know professional Traders take
the information that's put in front of
them and sometimes what's happens in the
market that's opposite of what the
information is telling them is just as
important as as what the information is
doing what the information tells you to
do right information tells you to buy
you buy Market goes up yeah that's right
but information tells you to sell and
the market keeps going up well wait stop
and think what's going on why isn't that
market selling off you know everything
sells says to sell off yet the Market's
rallying so there's some underlying
force in that market and this is a good
example I said you know um you know
traders
that that you know um you are how I say
are not good but you know people that
aren't consistent in the trading you
know that they're not able to put these
little pieces together and understand
that you know what doesn't happen is
just as important as what does happen
sometimes if not more
important and then you know what happens
we get back up here you make the swing
high and then you got some nice passive
offers coming in here 284 296 265 176
you know this this is volume that people
are up here yeah we get back up to 99 uh
112 even people are happy to sell up
here you know hey I'm I'm a seller I'm a
seller they're putting their hands out
you know people are buying it but they
can't move it any higher because they're
strong sellers up here Market starts
coming down then you get back down to
this area where you had the suppor of
buying
earlier right you know from 89 basically
to um you know up here to 92 a half I
mean you could see the volume sticking
out on on all these you know on All
These Bars here but then what happens
you get past that volume where's the
buyers they're gone right the buyers are
gone now and what happens boom you got
big stack selling a balance there Market
goes lower so when you have supportive
buying right and it's exhausted who's
there left to support the market it's
not there anymore so Market sells off
now what do you got you know you're
you're trading you know five ticks lower
five ticks lower and you know maybe some
of these people that were buying it been
here supporting that market coming in
here thinking hey you know there there
support I also want to support the
market now maybe they're turning Sellers
and hitting this bid on the way way down
so you know it's it's about
understanding what's happening in the
market rather than just taking an
indicator that says buy or sell you know
that's what orderflow does that's the
difference you know you ask yourself
what kind of Trader do you want to be do
you just want to be someone that's going
to sit there and follow um you know oh
this line turned blue it's time to buy
or this line turn red it's time to sell
no you know good Traders think you know
the best algorithm trading algorithm is
the one that's on you know in your brain
you know it's not the one that's you
know someone programmed it's it's you
know in your brain you know it I think
now more than ever is actually you know
a good time for Traders that you know
actually think in the market because you
know all these alos are chasing after
the same Alpha after the same thing
looking at the same thing and then you
know they they they they can't put
sometimes all these different pieces out
together at once I mean you know maybe
someday Jeff Bezos will come up with
some super trading algo for Amazon and
and release it but you know for now you
know I think you know the amount of
traders that actually sit there and make
trading decisions using their head is
there's an article I think it was like
at 10% now in the market you know
everything else is so computerized but
again you know just because you know
something that's computerized doesn't uh
doesn't mean it's great you know hell
you know sometimes you call you you call
the airline and you get this
touchtone system oh please enter
your um you know I your your ID number
you know your frequent fire number you
say it and then it repeat it repeats
back something completely different is
this correct
no oh okay you're you know it's just
every answer you give is it just reads
it as something completely different
it's so frustrating so you know for for
if you think computers you know are are
the greatest thing you know for trading
think again you know all these all these
hedge funds I say algo hedge funds say
all of them but you know a good portion
have been closing down over the last
several years why is one is they're all
chasing after the same thing you know
these little slices of profit that you
know it keep getting smaller and smaller
and smaller that these funds they know
they can't stay in business you know
they can't meet their payrolls I know
guys that work for these algo based
hedge funds get laid off because you
know they're they're yeah they're making
profits barely but you know more
importantly they can't meet payroll um
you know and it's it's it's you know
that doesn't get reported in the papers
you know just oh hedge funds are
suffering their biggest losses those
money people pull people pull their
money out yeah people are pulling the
money out because obviously because
index you know the S&P is up 10% and a
lot of these hedge funds are luckily
breaking even um you know people saying
you know what the am I giving my
money to some guy to take 2% off the top
and and profits well I can just put in
in a in a freaking mutual fund and get
better returns um you know that's why
hedge funds are suffering but you know
something that doesn't get reported are
a lot of these algorithmic hedge funds
they're closing shop they're just
closing
up anyway that's my rant on on that on
that side of the business you know I've
got a lot of rants lately but
um let me just see if I could pull in
one other Market if I could find the
chart really quick Japanese Yen yeah
we'll talk about Yen today or yesterday
so you know going back to
8:00 uh let's go back
here so you know here you did have a
Divergence but no ratio in the bar next
bar is green and then you got a a
bearish ratio here but this one bar
removed I would like it this bar to be
right
here um so anyway we we came off a bit
here um Delta scer gave a buy did pop up
here but it's you know it came down took
it took the low of this bar out by two
ticks red back up Delta scal gave
another sell here you do got a uh a nice
ratio up there followed by a stacked
imbalance here followed by you know some
trap traders in the next bar and you
know this was a nice move down here you
know you got sort of a lot of things
going off at once you got ratio you got
single print Delta scalper stacked
imbalance trap Traders and you go down
from you know the 90 even area down into
the uh eight you know
below
8990 um you do rally back up get up here
what time is this this is uh 1109 again
it's kind of similar you got a ratio
zero print um Delta scalper stack
imbalance and it comes back here now the
difference from this one here you got
the bearish Trap Traders here you got
the bullish trap Traders the market did
pop up um before selling
off and then you come down here you got
stacked in Balance right and you know I
I say when you get stacked in Balance
looks for the next bar for you know help
you give you confirmation and what do
you got in the next bar is you got the
opposite confirmation you've got a
bullish ratio you know if you get a
bearish ratio after a bar with an
imbalance stacked in Balance to me it's
all systems go turn off the lights you
know put the trade on turn off the
lights go take a piss come back
and you know hopefully it's in your
favor but still you know read the
orderflow what's happening you've got a
bearish sign followed by a bullish sign
do you want to stay in the trade
probably not and then next bar even
Delta scalper and the market pops up
here before going into the
close Okay so thanks for watching this
you I'll keep it short today said it was
kind of a quiet quiet day
um today a bit uh bit tired uh so thanks
for watching this if you want to learn
more about orderflow visit my website
orderflows
I didn't realize I got so many already
and
uh you know and so be notified when I
got a new video comes out so again visit
the www.fls.ga.gov